bei bewaffneten angriffen auf zwei
moscheen im neuseeländischen
christchurch werden mindestens 49
menschen getötet und zahlreiche weitere
schwer verletzt einer der angreifer
filmt die tat live bei ihm handelt es
sich offenbar um einen rechtsextremen
australier regierungschefin jóhanna
autorin spricht von einem gut
vorbereiteten terroranschlag
ich würde es als einen beispiellosen
gewaltakt beschreiben eine partie
neuseeland absolut keinen platz hat das
entspricht nicht dem was wir sind
unklar ist durch viele angreifer an den
anschlägen beteiligt waren laut polizei
werden vier verdächtige festgenommen
darunter eine frau demnach wurden zudem
zwei sprengsätze an autos entdeckt und
entschärft
aus einem im internet verbreiteten
manifest eines der mutmaßlichen
angreifer geht hervor dass die trat
rassistisch motiviert war